normalmente el ramadán en los últimos 10
años se ha convertido en ramadán
sangriento y ha sido la forma como los
palestinos y el mundo árabe o musulmán
mejor ha expresado su desacuerdo con
israelí con lo que llaman la ocupación
de gaza y cisjordania pero también en
estos últimos días como usted va nota la
violencia se ha exacerbado y sumado de
ambos bandos ya hay 29 muertos ha habido
enfrentamientos especialmente en
cisjordania y hamás está anunciando
permanentemente que va a volver a
cometer acciones fuertes entonces es una
suma de las dos cosas
y sin embargo hasta este viernes la
antigua ciudad de jerusalén estaba
exenta de estas agresiones porque cree
que la violencia ha llegado ahora está
allí
porque los últimos hechos que hubo esta
semana los dos días anteriores en
cisjordania fueron exacerbando los
ánimos pero es que va hasta ver lo que
es un viernes normal en jerusalén la
ciudad antigua la forma como la gente se
alborota especialmente los musulmanes y
cuando el ramadán es mucho más
complicado y ahora preciso que coincidir
en una fecha que es sagrada para las
religiones es usual que se tensión en
los ánimos que la policía esté muy
atenta a cualquier reacción y que dentro
de los sectores que son violentos en el
mundo musulmán instiguen a los
enfrentamientos a los choques ya estas
acciones que usualmente terminan en
hechos sangrientos algunas capturas y
luego vienen todos esos procesos de los
intercambios de las reseñas y las
reacciones de israel' fuertes contra la
franja de gaza y es una repetición que
parece fuera eterna en la historia de
estos dos pueblos